dieu le big bang et la science voilà
peut être un thème qui pourrait
alimenter les épreuves de philosophie
aujourd'hui encore en tout cas les
astrophysiciens poursuivent toujours
leurs recherches concernant la création
de l'univers des recherches qui
s'effectue entre autres dans les
laboratoires du cern à genève frédéric
monteil emmanuel maurel il était une
fois il y à 13 milliards 700 millions
d'années
le big bang partie d'un point minuscule
une énergie folle explose
l'univers est né aujourd'hui des
satellites comme celui ci baptisé
planque traque les dernières traces de
cet incroyable explosion sur terre aussi
les scientifiques cherchent à comprendre
et à reconstituer ce big bang en suisse
dans un tunnel souterrain de 27
kilomètres de long des protons un
composant des atomes sont projetées à
une vitesse prodigieuse 300 mille
kilomètres à la seconde jusqu'à la
collision
toutes ces recherches passionne les
frères bogdanoff habitué aux discussions
pointu qui est fascinant albert c'est
que c'est ces énergies dont on parle
sont extrêmement élevés sont de l'ordre
de 7
terra igor et grichka la firme notre
monde est régi par un ensemble de lois
extrêmement précises exemple la vitesse
de la lumière 299 1792 km et 458 mètres
par seconde
pas un de plus ou de moins autre exemple
les marguerites vous n'en trouverez
aucune qui possèdent ces spectacles pour
nous l'univers n'est absolument pas née
par hasard quand on constate tout ces
constantes
quand on constate que ces grandeurs
quantifier chiffrées précises
parfaitement ajustée qu'elles sont là et
que si elle avait été détraqué ici et là
à la 20e décimales par exemple au 100e
rang
un chiffre à la place d'un autre
l'universel restait chaotique
les frères bogdanoff y voit donc la main
d'un créateur pourquoi pas dieu une
thèse audacieuse réfutée par une partie
de la communauté scientifique
l'arbitrage viendra peut-être de
l'espace
le satellite planck doit livrer bientôt
de nouvelles images du big band
on en saura alors un peu plus sur la
création du monde
le cinéma